[Musique]
la reine elizabeth ii a déjà dit de
goderich quelle est la plus jolie petite
ville du canada
mariage parfait de paysages pittoresques
d'histoire et de culture
la journée commence au marché des
jardiniers à la place publique
[Musique]
la boulangère ce fut bordeaux n'arrivait
de france avec sa famille il y a une
dizaine d'années est consciente de la
chance qu'elle a travaillé ici pour moi
c'est du travail mais c'est vrai que
pour toulouse où tout ceux qui se
promènent cetc beaucoup de fans les gens
adorent
après le marché c'est ici que résidents
et touristes viennent se promener la
rivière madeleine l'ancien pont
ferroviaire les sentiers pédestres
c'est un lieu prisé des pêcheurs dont
mccallion qui a fait une heure et demie
de route pour le calme de la rivière aux
mafias fedex originaire de wuhan en
chine mme mccallion communique avec sa
famille chaque jour pour s'assurer que
personne n'ait contaminé pêché lui fait
apprécier encore plus sa vie ici qu'à
nice mot revenant à grains stéphanie
ce qui fait toute la beauté de
godderidge c'est le lac huron et ses
plages
amanda harrison et sa famille sont venus
de kate chemin pour en profiter nous tu
étais la pandémie elle ne serait jamais
venu à gauche
pendant que les touristes profitent de
la plage ce fibre donné toute sa famille
continue le travail à la ferme
mathieu a vécu à toronto mais il est de
retour à goodrich pour la qualité de vie
et le travail manuel
avec ses parents mes amis de toronto
quand ils viennent le visiter il
il pense beaucoup à venir habiter ici
parce qu'ils en ont marre de la ville
et c'est une petite un petit village
ouvert avec de la liberté tu peux encore
trouvé une maison à la voix pour
imprimer et beaucoup de gens qui
viennent pour la retraite mississauga de
partout laissant plus en plus de jeunes
aussi les plages sont plus remplies
maintenant après midi dans ce quartier
industriel une oasis la première micro
brasserie de goodrich
les jeunes qui reviennent s'installer
ici apporte avec lui le meilleur des
grandes villes
retour sur les berges du lac huron en
fin de journée on aime dire à cambridge
qu'on peut admirer les plus beaux
couchers de soleil impossible de ne pas
être d'accord ici philippe leblanc radio
canada goodrich en ontario